okay let's go where do we want to go
next let's go to Zack who's a member
Zack the member what the headline today
hey I'm surprised you were still
remembering
we have Colorado so I have copious notes
about you okay so my question was in
regards to policy which the thing about
me is I've always loved to do research
and learn and what I want to do is
understand policies like Medicare or for
all and thick and things like that I
want to know where would be a good place
to start doing that kind of research
specifically on Medicare for all or
anything or isn't OH
any sort of recent policy proposals
great but usually with that topic but I
think the first place to start is if
there's a policy proposal read the
original text of the policy proposal or
resolute house resolution Senate
whatever to start with have a full
understanding of that then start to
research how whatever the issue is has
been dealt with in the past by the
United States and by other countries so
like for example take Medicare for all
the first thing I would do is look at
the Medicare for all proposal from
whoever Bernie Sanders or whoever it is
look at the history of health care in
the United States going all the way back
as we are doing by the way in an
upcoming piece to the founding fathers
view on health care mandates look at how
other countries do health care then you
can start getting into things like the
Kaiser Family Foundation's cost analyses
of some of these proposals I mean
there's really no one way but the idea
is you've got to start with like the
news story or the bill and then build
the foundation out from there okay thank
you okay is that great to hear from you
appreciate it